collaborative work is everything we do
to come up with big new ideas and make
plans to bring them to life with other
people the modern workplace is set up
with so many ways to foster
collaboration meetings and brainstorming
sessions zooms and slack channels email
instant messaging so many tools to help
us work closely together and aspects of
this are great but we're doing more
collaborative work than ever before and
the problem is it's overloading us
from launching a new product to creating
a vaccine almost every Endeavor we do at
work requires working with others
towards a common goal and collaboration
is a great thing it can help us work
better and smarter it can help us come
up with ideas we never would have had on
our own and it can make us happier than
executing tasks alone but collaborative
work has risen 50 percent over the past
decade it's now taking up to 85 percent
of most people's work weeks and those
numbers from my research were
pre-pandemic studies show that people
are working five to eight hours more a
week now with collaborations drifting
earlier into the morning and later into
the evening when I came into this
research I was a hundred percent
convinced the enemy was external it was
emails time zones and demanding clients
to name just a few but after hundreds of
interviews I've discovered that even
when given a choice not to participate
people are taking on more collaborative
work than ever before we're just too
eager to jump into collaborations that
burn up our time and that might actually
run better without 20 people in The Fray
about 50 percent of the collaboration
overload problem starts with the beliefs
we have about ourselves and what it
means to be a good colleague and a
productive person these beliefs are hard
to change but if we examine them more
closely it can allow us to make stronger
choices about what we do at work and who
we do it with there are many triggers
that spark our desire to say yes so
often but today I want to focus on the
top three the desire to help others the
need for accomplishment and fear the
first trigger is the desire to help and
the desire to help others is a positive
constructive thing and an important
factor in success it fulfills a deep
need to be useful and bolster our
identity is a good teammate but it's
also one of the most significant drivers
of overload the more you're helpful the
more people ask for your help the
problem is that you get so bogged down
at helping that it prevents you from
meeting your own goals and over time you
become a bottleneck slowing others down
and this is all coming from a good place
the desire to help the second trigger is
the need for accomplishment our drive to
achieve is another admirable trait
critical to success and productivity in
the workplace and it also feels good as
little wins throughout the day and week
give us a burst of satisfaction the
issue is that the cycle can get
addictive it leads you to solve more and
more small problems for other people and
avoid the bigger thornier ones critical
to your own success this is my trigger
if I see a five minute window I will
inevitably try to jam 60 Minutes of
these little fixes into it and
completely ignore the three hours of
coordination I need to do to get my team
on board with what I'm up to and then I
end up overwhelmed six weeks out again
all from a good place of trying to get
something positive done the third
trigger is fear fear is a major driver
of overload today that takes several
forms the fear of missing out on better
projects better colleagues better
opportunities can become a persistent
nagging problem that never lets you rest
you feel a frantic need to be a part of
things worrying that it'll be your last
opportunity the fear of losing control
is just as bad it makes you reluctant to
delegate or connect the people around
you sentencing you to a life of doing
everything yourself and the fear of what
others will say is powerful too your
knee-jerk response becomes to say yes or
early and often so everyone can see how
responsive you are unfortunately these
fears Drive unproductive choices and
lead us into burnout today chances are
you recognize yourself in one or more of
these triggers and since I gave you
three triggers how about three ways to
deal with them number one learn to get
comfortable saying no don't let yourself
fall into the belief that you don't have
power in situations where your help is
requested remember that your answer
doesn't have to be a binary yes or no if
you get a request from a boss or a
colleague chances are they have no idea
what obligations you're juggling be
clear about what projects or deadlines
you have ahead ask them to help you
prioritize and if you just don't have
the bandwidth ask the person if you can
show them how to do the tasks they're
asking or discuss if there's a different
way to accomplish their goals at the end
of the day every Yes means saying no to
something else save your yeses for when
they really matter to you number two
remember you can delegate opting out of
a request can actually help others
become more self-reliant I found that
the most efficient collaborators get
their sense of worth not from always
giving input and being involved but from
developing others and positioning them
to grow too draw a line between tasks
that really do require you and lower
risk ones that you can delegate without
concern look for moments when you can
give partial Direction Empower someone
and then step out of the way and
celebrate others wins don't succumb to
the temptation to point out how you
would have done it differently number
three be intentional in crafting your
work Life High performers are strategic
in knowing their goals and identifying
what they can and should take on they
think about their priorities not only
for the week ahead but on a two to three
month time Horizon too so when a
collaboration surfaces make sure you're
not making an emotional decision based
on a false belief ask yourself how does
it align with my goals how much time and
energy will it take each week and what
are the upsides of the outcome try to
maximize those collaborations where you
want to do the work it contributes to
your goals and you're the best person to
do it the crazy thing about
collaboration overload is that it feels
good right up until it doesn't all it
takes is one thing too many to start it
downwards spiral remember you're the
only one who knows all your goals and
obligations and that you often have more
Choice than you think